[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous ce soir je vais vous
parler d'héritage ou plutôt la
difficulté justement d'évoquer ce sujet
soit dans le débat public dans les
débats ce milieu et dans le débat
politique aussi d'un point de vue
général ce que j'entends par héritage
cessons donc l'ensemble des
transmissions de patrimoine qui ont lieu
entre les parents et les enfants puis
souvent entre les conjoints des fois
avec des degrés plus éloignés de parenté
entre frères et soeurs en train non clé
un neveu ou une nièce et ses
transmissions peuvent être faites au
moment du décès d'un individu le plus
souvent l'héritage ou du vivant des
individus ça c'est aussi de plus en plus
fréquentes par les donations et
aujourd'hui en france ont fait face à
deux grandes évolutions qui s'opposent
la première c'est qu'on observe un
retour très marquée des héritages depuis
à peu près une cinquantaine d'années la
seconde c'est que ce retour qui est
indubitable se fait passe complètement
sous le radar se fait dans une
différence qui quasiment totale et c'est
cette opposition si aujourd'hui je vais
essayer de présenter déjà et de
comprendre avec vous
donc la première idée reçue qu'on
pourrait avoir j'ai déjà un petit peu
spoilé mon propos c'est de penser que
l'héritage serait seulement du passé
qu'il appartiendrait seulement
finalement au roman de maupassant de
balzac au roman du 19e ou à chaque fois
la figure du rentier ai souvent le
personnage central du roman ou en tout
cas l'héritage est un moment important
qui l'a déterminée souvent la
trajectoire du personnage ce que vous
montre ce graphique même si ça peut être
pas clair encore pour l'instant c'est
que c'est faux dans ce graphique ce
qu'on a fait c'est donc de décomposer le
patrimoine des ménages c'est à dire que
l'ensemble des biens soit des biens
immobiliers des actifs financiers des
biens professionnels qui sont détenus
par les ménages français
et comme vous le savez sûrement vous
avez deux moyens finalement d'avoir du
patrimoine soit en
ayant généralement à partir de votre
salaire est en place entre cet argent en
le faisant fructifier en faisant des
plus values et c est donc ça peut
prendre du temps ça peut conduire aussi
à des moins values s'est pas source
finalement de réussite et l'autre moyen
pas forcément plus rapide mais en tout
cas moins coûteux en essor c'est
simplement d'hériter évidemment ce
deuxième moyen vous ne choisissez pas
vous n'avez donc aucun de contrôle
dessus et donc ce qui est fait dans ce
graphique ce c2d composé donc au sein de
l'héritage pas de patrimoine pardon qu
est-ce qui va venir de ces héritages et
qu'est-ce qui vient de l'accumulation de
l'epargne des individus ce qu'on voit
c'est que jusqu'à la première guerre
mondiale et ce qu'est ce qu'on retrouve
évidemment dans les romans du xixème
l'héritage est prédominant l'héritage la
constituer pas loin de 80 % du
patrimoine total et donc l'epargne
constituent les 20% restant donc la
figure du self made men ou de la self
made woman à cette époque là est quelque
chose de très rare et donc c'est
vraiment les rentiers qui ont pouvoir
qui contrôle en tout cas une grande
partie du patrimoine puis ce que vous
voyez ensuite dans le graphique c'est
que au cours du 20e siècle vous avez une
sorte de courbe en u avec donc comme
vous savez un premier début du 20e
siècle qui est pour le moins d un peu
pour pour le moins agité donc on a deux
guerres mondiales une crise économique
de grande ampleur changement aussi d'un
point de vue général de du rôle de
l'état du montant aussi des prélèvements
de la fiscalité ce qui fait qu'on a
beaucoup moins de patrimoine et on a
surtout un moment de destruction aussi
des héritages donc on se retrouve dans
les années 70 à avoir on se poile
héritage qui représente seulement 1 de
sierre finalement du patrimoine total et
donc à ce moment-là l'épargnant
finalement domine l'héritier et depuis
les années 70 parce que vous voyez c'est
l'autre partie du on a une remontée du
patrimoine et une remontée aussi des
héritages et donc en 2010
l'héritage constituent la majeure partie
du patrimoine et représente quasiment
60% du patrimoine et ça ça s'explique on
rompt pour les mêmes raisons finalement
que la chute précédente ces raisons
inverses évidemment l'absence de guerre
le fait que les crises étaient absorbés
aussi par l'état notamment par la dette
publique comme ce convoi pour la crise
actuelle et aussi par des changements
dans la fiscalité
la deuxième idée reçue ça serait de
penser que aujourd'hui le travail paie
toujours et dit autrement que les
situations économiques des individus
dépendent de leur mairie de l'effort qui
fournit du niveau d'éducation des heures
travaillées et évidemment ce n'est pas
totalement faux mais c'est pas non plus
totalement vrai il s'en faut le
retrouver avec plusieurs sources
explication la première c'est évidemment
directement en lien avec ce que je vous
ai montré avancé que l'héritage est très
inégalement réparties tout le monde
mérite pas tout le mérite pas du même
montant et
vous avez en france aujourd'hui la
moitié de la population qui ne va
hériter au cours de sa vie de rien du
tout ou de montants très faible qui
s'élève à quelques centaines quelques
milliers d'euros maximum et à le bouder
finalement la distribution des richesses
vous avez donc les 10 % des individus
les plus riches qui vont hériter de la
moitié finalement de ce qui va être
transmis
pour être clarifié un petit peu ce
propos ce qu'on peut aussi avoir en tête
c'est parce que la figure finalement
qu'on peut mobiliser c'est la figure du
rentier c'est une figure compenser à
nouveau avoir disparu on pense que
rentiers et 2020 ne rimerait pas
vraiment et pourtant c'est plutôt le cas
c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui si vous
regardez donc parmi la génération des
personnes nées dans les années 70 et 80
on s'attend à ce que la proportion de
rentiers soit autour de 15 et 20% et
donc à rentiers qu'est ce que j'entends
par entier c'est ça va être des
personnes justement qu'ils vont recevoir
en héritage plus que ce que le français
moyen gagnant toute une vie de travail
donc en parle de rentiers si on pas
vraiment de personnes qui pourraient
vivre de ses héritages et ne pas
travailler dans l'image qu'on peut qu'on
peut avoir et donc il y représente
aujourd'hui entre 10 ou 15% de la
génération des personnes qui naissent
outils qui sont nés dans les années 70
quand c'était seulement finale 2 % de la
génération des personnes qui étaient nés
en eau début du 20e siècle donc on a
vraiment des héritiers qu'on croyait
finalement disparu qui reviennent en
force et d'un point de vue plus général
en france qu on observe finalement plus
que des changements dans le niveau
d'inégalité que soit du revenu ou de
patrimoine c'est vraiment un changement
dans la rôle finalement que peu joué le
mérite dans l'information des inégalités
se retrouvent aujourd'hui pour le
patrimoine mais aussi pour l'éducation
des inégalités qui sont de plus en plus
en fait reproduite d'une génération à
l'autre est de plus en plus irrité et
non plus méritée donc faux pas et
conclut exagéré le trim n'est pas revenu
à une société d'ancien régime où tout
serait déterminé à la naissance mais
donc le mythe d'une méritocratie
parfaite est loin d'être vérifié
aujourd'hui
ce qu'on peut retrouver aussi dans ce
rôle du mérite c'est on retrouve aussi
tout temps ou la distribution si
aujourd'hui vous regardez les
milliardaires donc les quelques
centaines de personnes qui détiennent un
gros montant de patrimoine dans lequel
la france ce qu'on voit c'est que
d'après le financial times qui a publié
un article à plus tard que la semaine
dernière en france la proportion
finalement d'héritiers parmi les
milliardaires s'élève à 80 % c'est à
dire que parmi les personnes qui sont
souvent présentés comme des grands
entrepreneurs vous avez une grande
partie finalement des personnes qui ont
hérité qui ont certes pu faire
fructifier ce capital de départ ça veut
pas dire qu'il a pas d'efforts derrière
mais en tout cas en france plus que dans
les autres pays on a bien même pas remis
et finalement le trait ou la
distribution on a donc ce poids de
l'héritage qui est très important
la troisième idée reçue c'est souvent
quelque chose qui est évoqué en économie
ça serait dire qu'entre inégalités a
d'un côté et efficacité de l'autre
efficacité ici c'est donc les
performances finalement économique d'un
pays ça peut être la croissance
économique directement sa capacité
d'innovation le dynamisme général de
l'économie entre ces deux des éléments
là il faudrait choisir c'est à dire
qu'on ne pourrait pas avoir une société
à la fois égalitaire une société
performante pourquoi généralement le
mécanisme qui est évoquée c'est de dire
que l'inégalité devra générer des
incitations si on est tous payés
exactement sur le même salaire il n'y a
pas de raison finalement de travailler
davantage d'heures de mettre un effort
plus important que son collègue vu qu'au
final vous aurez le même salaire donc
évidemment une égalité totale pourrait
nuire à l'efficacité
mais voilà on est souvent dans une
situation évidemment intermédiaire avec
des inégalités qui sont plutôt modéré
ça aussi c'est encore vous décevoir
peut-être mais c'est plutôt fort c'est à
dire que ce qu'on voit c'est que si on
regarde l'histoire économique des pays
d'où une histoire assez longue sur
plusieurs décennies voire plusieurs
siècles fait ça dans le cas de la france
et dans le cas par exemple des états
unis parce qu'on retrouve c'est qu'on a
donc des inégalités donc les périodes
plutôt d'inégalités très fortes sont si
des périodes pendant lesquelles la
croissance a souvent été plus faible est
l inverse des périodes d'inégalités pas
forcément plus modérée conduisent le
plus souvent à des niveaux de croissance
économique plus élevée d'accord donc
c'est compliqué dans ces études là de
savoir qui cause quoi d'accord quel est
vraiment le sens de la causalité entre
les deux mais ce qu'on trouve en tout
cas c'est que le lien entre les
inégalités et l'efficacité n'est pas si
clair que ça d'accord et aujourd'hui si
vous faites une photographie des pays
notamment des pays développés ce qu'on
voit c'est qu'il ya pas de lien très
clair des pays comme les pays nordiques
sont des fictions plutôt égalitaire mais
qui ont sont aussi plutôt performants en
termes de croissance économique et vous
avez des pays comme les etats-unis qui
sont des pays aujourd'hui très
inégalitaire mais tout aussi finalement
performant si on revient maintenant sur
les questions d'héritage on pourrait
dire est ce que tout ça s'applique aussi
à l'héritage la réponse est là aussi
plutôt oui c'est à dire que l'héritage
peut être davantage en fait une source
d'inefficacité
ça c'est une idée qui est très ancienne
qui remonte au 19ème siècle ou des
philosophes comme stuart mill par
exemple voyez dans l'héritage une menace
à la fois pour les ânes égalité mais
aussi en fait pour l'efficacité même du
pays ses capacités à nouveau à innover
et à se développer pourquoi parce que
quand vous recevez finalement un
héritage vous pouvez être incités à
moins travailler à vous mettre à mi
temps pas sûr que les militants existait
vraiment au 19e siècle à partir en
retraite plus tôt c est ça justement un
effet aujourd'hui qu'on retrouve dans
les études empiriques d'accord donc les
personnes qui reçoivent un héritage vont
partir à la retraite plus tôt vont un
travail et donc l'idée c'est pas de leur
reprocher ce comportement là que c'est
tout à fait
acceptable évidemment si demain c'est
exactement les mêmes effets que pour le
loto donc un gain de loterie tout comme
l'héritage peut conduire ce genre de
comportement
le problème c'est que si cette situation
et collective donc si vous avez une
grande partie de la population qui
hérite et qui à ce comportement bas ça
va rejaillir en fait sur la croissance
finalement du pays et on peut se
retrouver dans une société qui se prive
finalement de talent de force de travail
à cause de l'héritage d'accord et le
dernier élément ici c'est de bien avoir
en tête que soit un argument qui est
évoquée contre finalement la fiscalité
et notamment contre la fiscalité des
héritages c'est ce serait son caractère
justement inefficace ça serait de dire
si vous taxez l'héritage que je vais
transmettre ou que je vais recevoir
bahia fortes chances que ça change aussi
le comportement des individus des
personnes qui voient leur patrimoine
finalement taxes et aurait tendance à
peut-être moins épargné en amont à moins
travailler elle même ou voir à partir à
quitter le pays dans ce cas là c'est sur
ces problématiques vu que vous perdez
aussi c'est fort cela est cependant cet
argent là cet argent public
la nouveau ça veut pas dire la réponse
est plutôt c'est plutôt faut il peut
évidemment y avoir des gros réponses
comportementales de la part des
individus dati si vos taxes et demain
tout le monde à 100 % des personnes
fortement réagir tout à fait normal mais
disons que sur les systèmes qui existent
aujourd'hui sont pas des systèmes qui
sont confiscatoire on va avoir en fait
des réponses à nouveau qu'on retrouve
dans les études empiriques qui sont
plutôt modéré qui renvoie pas de
mouvement par exemple massifs d'exilés
scam on va pas de groupes sont actifs de
réduction d'epargne quand la taxation
finalement du patrimoine avec
contrairement à une idée reçue qu'on
pourrait avoir acquis est souvent remise
en avant
par tout un tas tout un tas d'acteurs
et pourtant donc malgré ce constat donc
je résume quand même là on en est on
constate du retour finalement de
l'héritage constat du retour de la
situation de rentiers avec une
proportion très importante de rentiers
et finalement une conséquence de
l'héritage qui retrouve non seulement
sur les inégalités mais aussi finalement
sur l'efficacité économique d'un pays
malgré tout ça
on a justement donc à un retour de
l'héritage qui se fait dans une
indifférence peut-être pas totale mais
en tout cas qui passe largement derrière
d'autres sujets de société et un premier
pas une première phase sont finalement
deux mesures et ça c'est de bien
comprendre que depuis les années 70 80
donc là on s'attendrait justement à
avoir une fiscalité des successions qui
pourrait permettre de corriger ces
éléments là c'est exactement fait
larvaires ce qui se passe c'est à dire
qu'on a depuis les années 70 80 donc
beaucoup de pays et notamment dans les
pays riches une suppression fait de ses
impôts sur les successions vous avez des
pays aussi différents que la norvège la
suède l'italie le canada la nouvelle
zélande qui ont de façon permanente ou
des fois de façon temporaire supprimer
cet impôt est il vraiment une tendance y
compris aux états unis par exemple qui
pendant très longtemps taxé très
fortement les successions aujourd'hui on
peut voir transmettre des patrimoines
sans trop de sans trop de problèmes la
france échappe un petit peu à ceux à ce
phénomène là mais c'est finalement une
échappée un peu en trompe-l'oeil cirque
en france l'impôt c'est plutôt maintenu
par rapport à d'autres pays on n'a pas
été réformé en profondeur en tout cas
depuis un petit bout de temps mais en
france vous avez donc simplement des
changements démographiques qui vont
faire qu'aujourd'hui tout la moitié en
fait des recettes fiscales de cet impôt
vient non pas des plus grosses
successions mais simplement des
personnes qui vont décéder sans enfant
aujourd'hui en france à vous avez des
grosses différences de taux d'imposition
selon le lien de parenté ça existe ça
dans tous les pays mais fait ça c'est un
cru en france sur les dernières
décennies et aujourd'hui les
transmissions entre conjoints sont
toutes exonérés de d'imposition donc le
taux d'imposition c'est zéro pour les
transmissions entre conjoints ça va
s'élever en moyenne à 1 2% de parents à
enfants mais ça sera en moyenne plus de
25 % pour les autres types de
transmissions à l'extérieur de la
semaine
est donc aujourd'hui si cet impôt se
maintient bien c'est grâce à kroos
finalement des personnes qui décèdent
sans enfant ensuite même si c'est plus
dû à mesure et on a un sujet qui est
très peu finalement abordé dans le débat
public en premier lieu finalement par
les chercheurs eux mêmes en grande
partie parce que les chercheurs
disposent de très peu finalement
d'information aujourd'hui sur qui hérite
de quoi qu'ils payent ce type d'impôt
donc c'est compliqué en fait aujourd'hui
de fournir des chiffres précis sur cette
question là et on retrouve en fait un
sujet assez peu abordé aussi dans le
débat politique si vous n'avez pas de
parti aujourd'hui en france qui va
mettre en avant ce genre de deux
réformes et peut-être d'un point de vue
plus anecdotique mais dans l'imaginaire
collectif aujourd'hui si vous comparez
les romans actuels et les romans du
xixème vous retrouvez donc là le rôle du
rentier finalement qui est aussi fort
finalement aujourd'hui que ce qu'il
était sous jacents et sous le sceau
balzac encore et surtout de caen débats
il y a le débat est trop souvent un
dialogue de sourds parce que les
arguments évoqués par à dire les
partisans d'une réforme fiscale et ses
opposants souvent vont jouer sur des
arguments qui sont complètement
différents les partisans vont souvent
mobilisé deux types d'arguments que j'ai
évoqué aussi qu'ils sont lésés chez de
l'héritage sur les inégalités et ses
effets aussi moins claires sur la
croissance économique et à linverse
c'est un polar qui est très impopulaire
au sein de la population est impopulaire
n'ont pas finalement pour ces raisons là
où parce que les gens adoreraient les
inégalités mais plutôt pour des raisons
morales en est aujourd'hui le principal
la principale opposition qui va avoir
lieu face à cet impôt c'est de dire que
c'est un impôt qui va générer des
conflits au sein de la famille qui
intervient au moment d'un décès dont
qu'au moment deuil donc c'est une forme
de taxation de la mort finalement c'est
une taxation qui va imposer finalement
les transmissions entre parents et
enfants qui sont motivés par l'altruisme
pas rentable et il aime on peut pas
écarter
ccc
ses arguments d'un revers de la main
mais on voit très bien qu'on se place
pas forcément sur la même dimension avec
une dimension économique d'un côté une
dimension morale de l'autre
on pouvait se dire finalement qu'on est
dans ce qui ressemble fortement une
impasse est-ce qu'on l'ait pour autant
j'ai trois nouvelles à vous annoncer la
première les plutôt mauvaise c'est qu'on
ne peut pas décréter comme ça une sortie
non parce qu'on peut pas décréter qu'un
débat ait lieu aucun débat de bonne
qualité et lieu où peut pas modifier
constamment les arguments des individus
la bonne nouvelle c'est qu'on peut quand
même les informer sur ce qui a été
montré dans des expériences notamment
souhaite c'est qu'en vous donner la
bonne information aux individus dont
l'idée n'est pas de donner des chèques
news individu aucun sens les opinions
peuvent parfois changer mais surtout se
baser maintenant sur des arguments et
les choix peuvent se faire finalement en
toute connaissance de cause
et la très bonne nouvelle qui peut être
excellente merkel qui est très bonne
c'est simplement de regarder ce que
l'histoire nous a appris ce qu'on sait
c'est que l'expérience historique soit
en france ou dans d'autres pays nous
montre qu'il n'ya aucune fatalité
finalement à vie dans une société
d'héritage à vivre dans une société
inégale ou injuste on fait surtout fasse
un choix de société ça qu'on a
aujourd'hui tous les outils finalement
notamment fiscaux pour finalement
contrôler autant que faire se peut
l'héritage et le patrimoine mais ce
qu'il faut bien comprendre c'est que
c'est avant tout un choix de société qui
est non du ressort des citoyens et les
citoyens doivent s'emparer de ce sujet
merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]